following ea's initial teaser Lee er
this week the company has now officially
announced EA sports UFC to the game will
launch in spring 2016 for Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 featuring on its cover
undefeated UFC champion Ronda Rousey
love her a Pokemon world of warcraft and
Game of Thrones as a gamer myself it's
pretty surreal to be on the cover of the
game and to have a woman on the cover of
a UFC game shows a lot of progress
Rousey set I'm really happy to be
involved with it EA sports UFC two and
some new modes not seen in the first
game released in 2014 including KO mode
and ultimate team the game also boasts a
revamped career mode which lets you
create female fighters the first game to
not as well as a new feature called
grapple assist that helps players master
their skills the first EA sports UFC
game was already gorgeous but the sequel
aims to take things like character
likenesses and animations to another
level ei set the game being really
really really ridiculously good looking
it's important to us the team is always
working to find ways to outdo themselves
that includes updates to the end game
lighting the facial animation system and
lots of new physics and rendering
details it all comes together in the
invite replays where you can really see
the fighter flinch a moment before a
huge strike lands sending ripples across
their face and how their hair whips
around with the force of the blow in
addition UFC to boasts a new knockout
physics systems to deliver more
realistic animation you can visit EA
sports UFC to website to get all the
details about the game's new features in
terms of EA sports UFC tues fighter
roster EA didn't share any names beyond
rousey at this point will be joined by
another fighter on the game's cover but
they say the game has the biggest ever
roster the game may look good but will
it play well we gave the first game of 5
out of 10 for more on UFC to your
already in the right place
you